things happen where we're not very good
at haunting our house and we don't do a
very good job so we have to get help so
we get Michael Keaton comes and as a you
know get in this film and he's dead in
this town
we need a living doll to me says
live people ignore the strange and
unusual
it's a really great character but you
know she's real I myself am
strange and unusual you know she's like
you know when you get in those moods
where you're really you feel really
dramatic and you just sigh all the time
well she's like that all the time
I feel you're lucky
I would rather talk about
[Music]
I play uh I guess a bad stepmother
uh oh not really I'm misdirected
ill-directed uh
woman who thinks she's an artist and was
just too defensive and too insecure and
too much of a nut case to succeed at
anything
including being a mother or stepmother
or wife
but I'm trying if you don't let me cut
out this house and make it my own I will
go instead okay and I will take you with
me it's the most creative of all the
movies I've done
Beetlejuice
[Music]
show up
six o'clock every morning three and a
half hours makeup hour and a half taking
it off at night doing and saying some of
the
some of the oddest
strangest
things I've ever said in front of a
camera
and having
one hell of a good time I just want you
two to know you're welcome in our house
anytime you want to come apart
Beetlejuice is kind of a creepy little
devilish funny character guy who's been
dead for 300 years and uh
he scares the living out of us also did
you work all night
[Music]
you're gonna see things in this movie
you've never seen before I think people
are gonna be mind blown by what they see
on a visual level I'm alive for a few
scenes in the beginning but then
basically I'm your average dead person
in this movie and finding out what
that's all about
Beetlejuice
[Music]
Beetlejuice I was attracted to this
movie because it's so unique you know it
when I read it I said well I just have
to be in this movie I try to think about
how people will react when they see it
and I think they'll just
say
what was that did you see that movie
it's like you have to see it it's weird
[Music]
I've learned a lot about special effects
in directing from from the director Tim
Burton who's great it's going to go down
in in my memory as one of those one of
the great movies that I'll ever work on
I think
[Music]
Senora
body on time okay
[Music]